people don't give a [ __ ] they don't care
they want to be socialists they want to
be alright they want to be a thing and
they want a game and they want to be on
line with people to think like them and
they want to make memes and I want to go
get laid they go to the [ __ ] Brooklyn
red Socialist Party event mixer I'll go
down there and suck a few communists off
what do I give a [ __ ] but this is what
they want to do they don't give a [ __ ]
they really don't care they want to get
a patreon going they want money they
want Fame what they don't want is any
real [ __ ] air these are not
revolutionaries and I've got to go burn
down the best yet it's not happening the
revolution isn't coming look at the
[ __ ] who say it is what is and if
we're gonna do they're gonna throw a
rock at what the White House would want
you nuts
with some fat head green haired some fat
green haired lesbians gonna Chuck a
[ __ ] chuck up nunchucks at the White
House and what do you think is gonna
happen what do you think and who know
you want those people to rule they might
be worse but this is what I mean I'm
sick of wearing this mantle of I don't
care no you don't care you don't [ __ ]
care you don't sit with Nick Bryant this
[ __ ] guy who's telling you about
torture all this [ __ ] for hours you
bring him on the show the guy's got
white hair he's telling you you bring
mark le Audion does a whole book about
the Russian mob and a trump and
everything like that you know it's like
so the whole things I remember stand up
at a great quote one state I was like
yep people say don't care but seems like
it didn't matter when I cared remember
when I cared no one gave a [ __ ] so to me
it's like listen do whatever you want
go get health care go get everything get
get everything do whatever you want to
do I can't I'm not gonna say stuff
that's gonna get me in trouble here but
do what you want to do listen I said as
a job this is a joke and I'm a comedian
but I said if you wanted to get the
government's attention this is a joke
and I'm a joker joke good joke good joke
but if you wanted to get the
government's attention you would strap a
bomb to a two-year-old and send that
toddler into a Grand Central every week
you would go to a different station and
a toddler walk in and this is fun I did
this onstage was kind of funny because I
do it
toddler walking it's very funny but a
lot of people don't laugh but it's very
funny to a few certain select people in
the room that are really they're really
over life so they think this shit's good
so I do the toddler walk and I go and
the toddler just she's got a little bear
attached to him but it's a bomb and he
just goes wild and then and then people
listen you're gonna get some attention
people will they'll be like these these
[ __ ] are willing to send in toddlers
to train stations at rush hour and blow
them up
I'm not saying to do that